[Music]
thank you
hello hello everybody out there in
Milwaukee and out on the internet
listening to our show this is wisdom for
life we're doing a special broadcast we
are all observing our social distancing
so we're trying out something new Dan
and I are each of us logging in and
recording on RN so hopefully this is
going to be a great show for you today
we're going to talk about uh a
distinction that's important in
philosophy that you might not think has
a big part of of your life but actually
is quite important and it's the
difference between real or actual and
apparent goods and bad so let me uh turn
it over just for a second to my co-host
Dan Hayes hey thank you very much Greg
it is a lovely day got a little sunshine
going on and you know we're all hunkered
down in our houses to to the whole
uh coronavirus and um hopefully uh in
this time we realize that maybe some of
the things that we thought are good are
not actually good and that will allow
you to have the ability to focus more on
the things that are actually good
yeah and we can say similarly about
things that people consider to be bad
that maybe some of them really are bad
but quite a few of them turn out to be
not so bad after all and philosophy
gives us resources for not only deciding
these sorts of questions is something
really good does it just appear to be
good is something bad does it just
appear to be bad but it also helps us to
prioritize between them and now uh in a
time of Crisis we actually do have to do
a lot of prioritization don't we we have
to decide what we're going to give our
time to what we're going to spend money
on who we're going to do things for who
we're going to say no maybe not right
now you know not today right
so
um let's uh maybe let's talk about the
uh Aristotelian version of this
okay so Aristotle is a pretty
representative figure in in relation to
this you could say that his take is kind
of similar to that of Plato uh so two
different schools that that also get
lumped together and then there's a lot
of
um early medieval and uh late medieval
and modern philosophers who who take up
Aristotle's position in this way even if
they're not aristotelians and Aristotle
tells us that as human beings we're
confronted with a variety of things that
are good and they're good in different
ways so he will distinguish between
goodness in terms of say the just and
its opposite the unjust that you know
the right and the wrong but he also
talks about something that we might
consider more aesthetic he talks about
the beautiful and the Ugly which also
can be translated as the Noble in the
base or the fair and the foul and they
need to acts about pleasure and unlike
some other philosophical positions
Aristotle considers play pleasure to be
a good you know so when we sit in front
of the TV and and as we've been doing
tune into a show and put our feet up and
uh eat a little snack or something like
that that's that's Pleasant right it's
not uh producing Justice in the world
they're doing something you know an
inherently beautiful or Noble but it's
Pleasant and that's also good and pain
or suffering uh Aristotle views as bad
and so there's different modalities and
then we can talk about different big
basic objects and when I when I talk to
students about this in classes we're
usually looking at Aristotle's Nick and
McCain ethics book one where he talks
about different kinds of life and
happiness and we ask well what what are
the components of the good life what
matters to you that's another way of
putting it to these students and they'll
say usually they'll say things like I
value my family or I value my friends
are having a good career and then we
start peeling things back a little bit
and we say okay that's fine those are
the stock and answers what else matters
to you and some of them will come
straight out and say I want to be rich I
need to have money either to like be
able to buy all the things that I want
or a sense of security or it could be a
status symbol and once they start
talking about status then you know we
can start talking about what the Greeks
called honor and that's something people
want as well right and these are all
goods for Aristotle but they're not the
good they're not what's most good but
you're going to say something yeah isn't
this the uh one of the you know
arguments against Aristotle's argument
of the good in that he requires or is
expecting that to have the good life
um you have to have certain Goods like
you know friends for good conversation
and a little bit of money so you can
have like a at least a modicum of
pressure pleasure in one's life and for
a lot of people those things may not
ever be afforded to them
well that's not really an argument
against
Aristotle's position that would be sort
of realizing the implication that for
many people
the Aristotelian good life might not be
realizable but that doesn't mean that we
can't have a semi-good Aristotelian life
or anything like that right A lot of
times we're we're you know these moral
theories we don't we don't say Well
everybody's going to be reaching the
Pinnacle of it
um they can still provide us guidance so
Aristotle you know he doesn't say that
somebody let's talk about what he
considers to be really good he calls it
virtuous activity so that's kind of
old-fashioned sounding but when we talk
about meaningful or moral activity
something where you're doing good in the
world and you're it's flowing from the
kind of person that you've become that
for Aristotle is what's what's most
satisfying most and it's also most
pleasant too
um so you know the virtues are things
like justice or courage or Temperance or
even Good Humor According to Aristotle
being able to laugh with people but not
give a offense to them in in the process
not cause them undue pain so being able
to do these things which could fit in
very well with our careers or could fit
in very well with taking care of a
person
um you know you're right in a sense that
Aristotle thought that it was going to
be mostly the upper and middle classes
who would enjoy this in the Greece of
his time but contemporary aristotelians
say that this is something that is
possible for if not necessarily all
people at least most people even outside
of the you know developed world in in
the third world because you know for
Aristotle the core of of what's good is
at least if we're looking at the act of
life it's developing and and exercising
these virtues these traits of character
that are stable that are chosen that are
that are good for us and good for other
people and then the other stuff you can
think of it is sort of like the icing on
the cake you still have cake even if you
don't have icing but but it's it's good
to have people you know relationships uh
friends family colleagues that you can
engage with it's good to have some means
so that you're not stuck living on the
streets or in Dire Straits and those are
the the components of happiness but to
go back to the issue of the good
Aristotle thinks that all of these
things are good they're just not all as
good as each other and so if we so go
ahead
to your point you're talking about like
uh moral virtue you're talking about
hexas for that action correct
yeah and so we should we should say what
that means so hexis is a Greek term and
it comes from the word to have and so
what we've got in in that it often gets
translated as habit but it's it's a
little bit stronger than it just a habit
is it not on an action chosen knowingly
for its own sake
well it produces those but but a hexis
is actually the disposition that
produces those so if you let's let's
take some concrete examples let's take
courage because that's really applicable
right now there's a lot of people who
are engaging in actions right now that
are courageous and there's a lot of
people that are engaging in actions that
are cowardly or on the other extreme
rash or foolhardy right so the people
who say
well okay so okay I I was going to talk
about the spring the spring break thing
first and Corona parties but yeah let's
talk about toilet paper so hoarding
hoarding behavior is arguably a cowardly
act that's uh just act
it's also an unjust act that's right and
and it might also you know be vicious in
other ways too but if you think about
the inability to deal with one's own
fear anxiety in a time of uncertainty
and this this you know acquisitive drive
to accumulate as much of this product as
possible and it is unjust because it
deprives other people of the opportunity
to to have what they need in the process
um now you could say is is this a real
sign of the person's character
um it could be because some people
actually are cowardly in that way they
are it's become part of their character
right other people sometimes just fail
and Aristotle calls this lack of
self-control or in Greek acracia it's
often translated as incontinence which
is kind of ironic in terms of toilet
paper right because we we understand
incontinence in a very narrow way the
the people who translated Aristotle you
know in a couple century years ago
understood it as like giving in to your
desires or fears or other other things
that are driving you when reason would
tell you no no you don't need to do this
and so yeah hoarding toilet paper uh is
an example of cowardly action it's not
courageous and some people might spin it
that way oh I'm you know saving my
family by getting myself 256 rolls no I
don't think so you know or some people
like the guy who was uh essentially
profiteering you know he filled up an
entire storage locker yeah with uh the
hand sanitizer yeah but also I think
toilet paper right
um
sure
okay yeah so so any of these Goods right
yeah he might tell himself oh I'm being
courageous I'm being bold I'm being an
entrepreneur by cornering the market but
it's really a cowardly act right and
then on the other side the people who
are unwilling to take any precautions
and maybe even are like showing us how
um you know how unafraid they are yeah
having Corona parties or things like
that that's that's not that's not
courage that is foolhardiness you know
so so those you know that that's a
concrete example I think that can help
us understand it and you can also ask
about motivation
what would motivate somebody to say
um I'm gonna you know go on spring break
anyway well you they they came out and
said it we paid for it already so money
is more important than
behaving in a prudent way for them you
know and they've done a prioritization
between two different Goods money is a
good you know uh losing money is a bad
thing but it's not as important in the
grand scheme of things than keeping
people safe and remaining healthy
yourself
so that's how an Aristotelian would look
at these sorts of things I feel like we
could move to another Hellenistic school
um we have the stoics and their
dichotomy of how what things are good
and what things are not good and so the
the major basis the stoics Define as
what is good is those things that are
within your complete control and so
those are your actions and your
aversions and your desires and and
everything else falls into uh well
category of indifference
sort of the the bad Falls within the
sphere of your control too though oh
absolutely so so it's almost as if
you've got like two extremes right that
that come together in the middle what's
in our control that's good what's in our
control that's bad and then everything
else for them is strictly speaking
indifferent although they they do and
we'll talk about this in a bit they do
distinguish between preferred and
dejected indifference which confuses
people when they hear that
I like the idea that um there's say uh
two sets of things that you might
consider good and say you have a
daughter and say you have
um
the ability to get some ice cream would
you ever would you ever trade uh your
daughter for any amount of ice cream
versus well I hope not I hope not and
and the vast majority of us will say no
there's no amount of ice cream that we
will ever uh
trade our daughter substitute yeah on
whereas if you have money money is in
the same level of good uh idea of a good
and you definitely trade money for ice
cream that's not a problem but you like
automatically go into this like
cognitive uh you have to make this moral
decision about trading something that is
of of
absolutely different value for something
that is not and so this is a two-tiered
level of what is uh potential goods and
so the goods are the things
uh in stoic uh are those things that are
under control as well as all the things
that are bad and everything are like
dependent upon the choices so money in
this case as a a preferred indifference
um can be used for either good or bad
ends and so in and of itself it is not
good or bad is how you use it
yeah that's right and
we can say that from the stoic
perspective there's a whole bunch of
things that fit in there and this is
where I think they at least at first
they might lose a lot of people because
the stoics you know a lot of us can say
ah money that's not that important but
the stoics also say that about health
and illness right and about other good
what we what we they say they're not
actually rightly called Goods but things
that that Ordinary People would call
Goods of the body like attractiveness or
strength or reputation
yeah reputation social status uh whether
or not you get promoted or not
um all of those things they would say
are strictly speaking indifference and
so they don't have they're not rightly
called good or bad and where we make
ourselves miserable in a lot of cases is
by calling them good or bad and then
when we do that we pursue those things
or we avoid them so if I think that
getting sick is a really bad thing then
I will do whatever I can to avoid that
and you know this isn't to say that a
stoic would be Cavalier about our our
bodies and say oh and I'm just going to
go out there and forget social
distancing and I'm not going to wash my
hands or anything like that that would
be imprudent right absolutely um
but they they would tell us that in this
time of Crisis we we really should be
placing the focus on what's most
properly ours whether or not we're good
or bad people and the actions that that
stem from that so they they line up with
a
aristotelians uh in that respect right
yeah virtue is a good thing Vice is a
bad thing but where they differ is
saying strictly speaking those are the
only good or bad things and everything
else is in this middle category like you
said it's a two-tier system so that
um whatever value and and things do have
values whatever value you get from
pleasure or wealth or reputation no
amount of it heaped up will ever make
you a good person and the goodness of
virtue it outweighs all of those things
and the Badness of Vice so no amount of
being you know well equipped having as
much much pleasure as possible all sorts
of social connections none of that will
ever make up for being a bad person and
doing bad things no amount of toilet
paper or hand sanitizer will make you a
good person if you got them in bad ways
yeah now we should talk about
um what the stoics call use or dealing
with things dealing with indifference
because this is where it starts to
become I think if people were lost
before that and they're like yeah I'm
not I'm not going to buy into that now
they can say okay I can kind of get
behind this so while indifference
themselves are neither good nor bad and
they're strictly speaking not really in
our control
um although we can you know influence
them to some some degree we don't
control the outcomes how we use all
these things the stoics are really clear
that is in our control absolutely and
and that is good or bad so whether you
know let's say you just happen to find
yourself with a stash of toilet paper
because your relative who lives in your
house uh did Panic by and ordered a
whole bunch of it and you've got like I
don't know 150 rolls which I think a lot
of people would consider to be vast
wealth at this time
um
are you smog sitting upon a tower of
white gold there
exactly so let's say you had that right
now
that by itself is neither good nor bad
but what you do with it really matters
do you continue to hoard it do you are
you like are you like a dragon you know
rolling around and it's uh it's horde uh
it's so soft and comfy
exactly
looking looking at it you know and
marveling at how well equipped you are
or do you you know do things like see
whether you're neighbors uh are in need
and go to them and and maybe you give
them a roll once in a while you don't
just give away the whole stash now doing
that would be how you exercise these
virtues like justice or Prudence you
know practical wisdom and so so let's go
to Justice there so we have these okay
you know
um the Justice goes down to the actions
and how we should be treating others uh
yeah and so if I have a glut and I know
my my neighbors around me are are in
dire need
um of either a bidet or uh some toilet
paper then it would be just for me as a
neighbor to
um give them something that I have a
glut of and they are uh absolutely
bricked up deprived of yeah yeah I think
that that's completely right
um and you know we could add to this
I think a lot of people I I don't know
what it's like where where you are but
we live in an apartment building and we
know some of our neighbors and we don't
know the rest and now we're probably not
going to be like going door to door and
knocking and saying is there anything
you need and we and we frankly don't
have uh you know enough stuff to do that
with anyway
um but let's say we did
is there anything like a duty to not
just you know wait passively for one of
your neighbors to need help but to go
out and see who does need help is that
part of Justice
what do you think
um
I guess it depends upon your means
um and and also like for example I have
a friend who is uh circulating a letter
in his part of the neighborhood
um saying like you know he's young envir
Isle and has transportation and will go
out and
um acquire things if people need to go
him to go to the store for them or
something along those lines and so
um like me or him going out of the store
is significantly less dangerous than
someone that is uh elderly and
potentially immunocompromised and so I
feel like there there is a a greater
requirement depending on the greater uh
difference in on what your neighbors
need versus what you can provide
and so it's not like I should just be
giving up
everything and all my time for anyone
who asks it but definitely there are
certain people that are in the greatest
need and we I feel that we have a
obligation to uh support them
yeah I think that makes really good
sense and
that
um where a distinction that we make in
moral philosophy
can be quite helpful not everybody buys
into this distinction but sometimes we
talk about perfect and imperfect duties
a perfect Duty would be one or a strict
Duty and then uh there's a very a
variety of words where we can call them
meritorious or super derogatory and the
basic idea is this there's some things
where we have a we have a moral duty to
act either to do something or not to do
something to prevent something to
promote something and we have it at at
that time and there's no exception to it
so if I see you fall down a well I
shouldn't say well you know I do have a
duty to help people when they're in a
well but not in this case you know I'll
make an exception for this I I need to
act on on that particular situation or
if if you need to get to the hospital
you know let's say you've been injured
in some terrible way I could say well
you know there's a lot of people who
need to go to the hospital maybe I'll
find another one instead of Dan no that
that's not that's oh yeah I have a
strict Duty right and there's a lot of
strict duties that way and then we have
others where we get to decide where we
want to devote our our resources you
know I think you're right we we do have
a duty to be as as people would call it
being kind or beneficent or generous to
others
um even more so I would say in in a
crisis
um but it doesn't say that we have to do
that for every single person all the
time and there's I think there's a
danger for quite a few people of
something like uh they could go through
all their resources which is a problem
then for them but but also we do this
psychologically and people get burned
out this feeling that we have to be
there for everybody all of the time it
might be enough that we just do some
good rather than trying to do all the
good right right if you become burned
out then you are no longer a good to
yourself or anyone else so there's you
need to have at least something reserved
for yourself in order to keep on going
that's true and and you know it's
interesting I was talking with my
students about this before in ethics
classes when we would get to certain uh
parts of the content is there a duty to
self-care do we have a moral obligation
to take care of ourselves not only a
sort of selfish way where we're like
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna buy up all of
the luxury skin products because that's
my my self-care and forget about the
poor or anything like that no but but
you know like basic self maintenance and
Care getting enough sleep
um making sure to uh you know engage in
personal hygiene
um saying no to certain
expectations or requirements or or
obligations when we're at the risk of
being burnt out all of those things I
think would would fit in with that that
self-care but going going back to
talking about the good so we've brought
up two different schools right the
stoics and the aristotelians
and there is a big difference between
them in that the stoics would say Hey
you aristotelians a lot of the things
that you call good aren't really good
and a lot of the things you call bad
aren't really bad they're actually
indifference now some people uh said
that ah this is just a verbal argument
because the stoics still end up behaving
like you know with this preferred and
rejected indifference they're doing the
same thing as as anybody else whether
it's Aristotle or you know Aquinas or
Augustine or Plato
um it's really just a terminological
difference I've never bought that I
think the stoics and the aristotelians
really are on different pages when it
comes to that what do you think I I do
agree in that regard
um even though so this is kind of the
idea of what a performative ethics and
that from different ethical backgrounds
you can come to similar ethical outcomes
um but I do think especially with the
idea that
um the Aristotelian steel value
pleasure at least modicums to pleasure
um as the good then there are people
that are fundamentally unable to acquire
that especially if you think of like
people that are uh
yeah yeah and horrible prisons or in
slavery of that sort of thing it becomes
very difficult to ever reach a uh life
of flourishing
well you know Aristotle doesn't say that
pleasure is part of the life of
flourishing
he says that that virtuous activity is
is the core component of that and that
you will have some pleasure in in doing
that and then having you know friends or
or you know relationships and some small
amount of of
means as well he in saying that pleasure
is a good he's not saying that it has to
be there in the the best life but I
think you and I are are we're sort of
emphasizing different things here you're
you're your concern is more can
everybody have this mine is less are
these fundamentally different
perspectives just in what they Define as
good or bad you know
well I'm I'm less concerned about
whether everybody could enjoy the best
life or anything like that in terms of
whether whether uh an Ethics is is a
viable ethics or not
um it could be that Aristotle or let's
say we pick somebody else and we don't
we're not using Aristotle we're going to
call them uh Professor X Professor X
comes by and says
human happiness consists in just one
thing and that one thing is only
available to the most absolutely
developed and possessed of resources
people so only you know a tiny fragment
of the population will ever enjoy it
ever in the history of mankind
so you know you'd be saying well he's
got to be wrong because you know
happiness has to be enjoyed by more
people than just a few but what if he
actually was right if he was right which
is all I'm really worried about then
that would be a bad implication we'd all
be in a terrible situation where none of
us could really be happy but he'd still
be right and so I I don't think that
whether whether happiness can be enjoyed
by everybody is the index of whether a
moral theory is correct or not I think I
think I can agree in some sense and say
look if it's something like Professor X
that's so crazy uh that can't possibly
be the case because if it is we're all
totally you know uh out to sea
um but you know the fact that some
people you know let's think about Plato
Plato places the good similarly in the
development of virtue but it's also in
you know the possession of wisdom and
not everybody can can afford a life in
which they are going to be devoting
themselves to that that doesn't mean
that Plato's automatically wrong because
of that
um you know it's interesting because
people make similar arguments against
the stoics ah the way the way of life
you're choosing is so hard who could
ever do that you say the Sage only comes
around every 500 years so well you know
the perfect stoic is very rare and you
can easily respond to them and say well
you know we're not saying we're trying
to be the perfect stoic we're just
trying to make our lives incrementally
better and we're looking for some
guidance on what we should choose and
what we should reject and how we ought
to think about things and
um you know whether it's going to help
us along on the way and and here's so
I'll shut up in a second lately say some
stuff because I can see you thinking
about things
um so the stoic way of doing that is one
blueprint right and that blueprint
includes some ideas about what's good
and what's bad and the Aristotelian way
of looking at it is another blueprint
and they overlapped to some degree and
then they're different in in some degree
so you almost got a lot you got to pick
which one you're going to follow or you
can say well maybe both of them are
wrong could be
and maybe the best side answer is I
don't know and and hold off uh judgment
there
um but
the
I wanted to get to like the distinction
of not like who can ex expect to
actually achieve these goals but
um the the difference
um that you were trying that you were uh
trying to enumerate with between the
stove View and the Aristotelian view
um that the recitalian has like a grab
bag of values and I guess that's the
question I want to answer
yeah except it's not it's not a grab bag
that's actually a great way to to start
thinking about it because
I think and I see this again when my
students first started encountering it
they write papers on Aristotle and
they're like well Aristotle thinks that
the happy life and the good is just all
these different things then they list a
whole bunch of stuff and there's no
ordering to it there's no arrangement to
it there's no you could say
hierarchization or prioritization within
it for Aristotle in saying that all of
these things are good doesn't mean that
they're they're all like on the same
level it means that there's a
recognition that there's something
positive there so when I have a snack
and like I like to take chocolate chips
and uh I dip my spoon in peanut butter
and then I stick it in the chocolate
chips and I put pop that in my mouth and
I chew on it and I get effectively the
same thing the Reese's Peanut Butter Cup
would be only much cheaper and I can you
know have as much of it as I want or as
little as I want spike
yeah exactly so that's that's Pleasant
and that is good and and there's it's
good for it's not just good in one way
it's good in that I like the taste of it
and it makes me you know uh we won't say
happy in any sort of full sense but it
makes me happy a little bit and and
you're right there's there's physical
correlates to it right
um and it's we can say similar things
too about like when so when we finish
recording this we have a sense of
accomplishment and that's better
than the at least it should be better
um if I'm properly ordered and organized
that should be better in terms of the
amount of goodness or the kind of
goodness the quali quality of it then
just popping the the chocolate and
peanut butter in my mouth you know and
so Aristotle sets up and I think most
most um people who organize their life
fairly rationally they they do this they
say some things are more important than
others it doesn't mean that the other
thing isn't isn't good
but it's just not as good although some
of them could be apparent Goods think
about like um you know think about hard
drugs
um oh yeah heroin you know not really a
good thing intensely pleasurable for
people but it it ruins people's lives
you know Aristotle I use this again as
an example Aristotle thinks you can have
a right amount of drinking and it's not
conducive to health of course but it
could be good for other things there is
no like virtuous mean of taking heroin
right there's no right amount to take
it's all it's always going to be bad for
you and if you want to go to alcohol I
guess for certain people who are
alcoholics you know at that point in
time yeah yeah no no amount of alcohol
is going to be good for you exactly yeah
and there's always you know so this this
goes back to our our theme the real good
versus the apparent Goods so many of the
things that we do in life where we make
bad or also hasty decisions it's because
we're taking things that are only
apparent Goods as being genuine Goods so
this or apparent bads as as genuine bads
this kind of brings me to the idea of
the the hedonic cycle and so okay A lot
of times you got to explain that yeah
absolutely I'm going to explain it right
now so the hedonic cycle is the idea
that
um uh a lot of times we are are
requesting to gain something so say um
that that new promotion at work or that
that new car or that whatever that new
dress any any physical tangible object
and and you get it and you get that
little dopamine Spike but
um shortly thereafter uh that object
isn't going to give you continue to give
you that adopamine Spike and you reset
back to a standard level of Happiness
yeah um and this actually works both
ways and so you look at people who
become like double to quadruple amputees
and at first they're like in a really
bad state but after over time they come
back to kind of a relative mean
um happiness and and you can see this
also really distinctly in um Victor
Frankel's work uh man search for meaning
where he describes this from his
experience in the concentration camps in
Germany during World War II and how he
could see see that people even in this
abjectively bad experience were having
were uh relatively happy to what they
were even before this and
um and it kind of depends on one's uh
View and state of mind and so the idea
is to try to not be uh totally
influenced on those things that will
only give you momentary happiness
yeah not take them as if they're going
to be reliable continual providers you
might say right or you know if we want
to put it in like business terms good
earners
now it's interesting as you're talking
about that I was thinking one of the
examples that people want to buy a new
video game right and they're like oh
this is going to be great then they line
up around the block to get it or you
know people do this with technology
stuff like Apple products you see them
gotta get that iPhone yeah exactly and
it's not going to be any different if
you get it being the first person or
20th person in line or whether you get
it a week later it's still the the same
basic piece of technology but you know a
really well-designed game is going to
provide
um
more of that over time
than a poorly designed let's just get it
out there to make a quick Buck kind of
game right and this is why people
gravitate to that we could say that
about literature too right if you're
reading
cheap let's you know knock out a
thousand words real quick uh about this
romance stuff yeah uh if you're or we
could talk about Media stuff too you
know a lot of the news that we we
consume is just garbage a lot of the
times it's people like just chattering
about the same stuff or you turn on the
radio and they're like well we don't
know what the story is but we'll update
you as soon as possible you know and
you're like Ah that's the same as an
hour ago so there's there's things that
will provide us with
um Rich engagement
and a lot of that is going to be sad you
know satisfying for us pleasurable for
us
um
and so you know if we think about is it
going back now to Virtue ethics what it
means to have a virtue when it's become
part of Who You Are
is like that it's something that you you
respond to situations
um in a very flexible way uh but but in
a consistent way and so you do justice
or you do courage or you do generosity
and you know you can rely on that
continually happening and it's a way of
like
um being being involved in reality as an
agent but also experiencing reality
that is quite satisfying and I think
that can you know that might be one way
off the hedonic treadmill cultivating
things like that whereas you know buying
the next consumer product
or you know going back to our old
example being able to look at your
massive mountain of toilet paper in the
The Pantry
um or wherever you've put it out in the
garage
um and piled up on your bed because it's
the most important thing in your life
that's that's not gonna that's not gonna
help you very long right right and and
so I wanted a quick touch on uh kind of
a Buddhist topic of yeah
um
uh emptiness and so this is an idea that
we
are the ones that are defining what
things are in like good or bad terms and
so you know we hear a um the traffic
outside our window and we might consider
that to be annoying or like you know uh
the neighborhood kids yelling and
screaming outside the window and
um we're the ones that are defining that
that is a good or a bad thing and in and
of itself all it is is in this case
sound waves and we are perceiving these
sound waves within our Consciousness and
if you you stop from the point where you
are assigning that sound wave to a
object and then also assigning that
sound wave to or that object to a good
or bad judgment if you just look at it
as something that appears in
consciousness
it allows you to take back and and walk
back and and realize the
the very basics of the the only thing
that is at this point is a sound in
Consciousness and you can you have the
ability because it is only resides
within your Consciousness to
uh decide for yourself if you want to
consider that a good or a bad thing
yeah and and um
what that points to is our agency and
that we have a responsibility and this
is something we've talked about before
I think a lot of people view themselves
as just sort of the prey of their
emotions or their their seemingly
natural but actually habitual responses
to things labeling them classifying them
and then and then almost like
automatically after the judgment is made
reacting to them and a main part of the
the whole idea behind
um
weaning yourself away this isn't the way
Buddhists put it but I think it's
actually consistent with Buddhism
weaning yourself away from suffering
that you're undergoing that you don't
have to be is realizing that the problem
isn't out there by itself the problem is
you making it a problem and that's very
similar to you know stoicism and
interestingly I think that although
aristotelians haven't really stressed
this that much there's there's plenty of
resources there in Aristotle for talking
about things in in such a way you know
um as as to do that I think it's
something inherent in a lot of wisdom
traditions and a lot of virtue ethics
this uh realization of our our role in
things so we have
could talk about we've from
stole it from uh Reddit here and from
user Ash 640
um after being quarantined has anyone
discovered that they have actually been
an introvert this whole time
any thoughts on that
yeah so that I mean that's a big open
question and we'll have to do a little
bit of
um work to make a connect up with this
topic of what's really good what's
really bad so if somebody's an introvert
you know that means that they enjoy
being by themselves and you know
correlatively they're not super happy
about being thrown into situations where
they are stuck in the churn with other
people bouncing ideas and and energy off
of them all day long right they'd prefer
sometimes there can be very high
functioning introverts where they are
good at networking and leading meetings
and all that sort of stuff but it takes
a toll on them and they need to to
withdraw and I think you're you're more
introverted than I am I'm not a pure
extrovert in that I I really need that
sort of interaction the way some people
if they're not getting it being
quarantined is is awful for them
um but um I I well I like it
um I can also be on my own so I'm kind
of like in the middle but I think you're
more introverted right where so talk
about that a little bit
um so yeah I find um I'm actually very
good in Social settings and have the
ability to uh have small talk or deep
conversations with you know small to
large groups I I lead
um large groups on a like a weekly to
multi-weekly basis
um but it is still like after I've done
that for a couple hours
this is incredibly draining I need to
withdraw myself in order to regain that
stamina but I think in regards to this
question it's interesting because this
whole situation is allowing a lot of
people to because we are being forced
into a certain amount of isolation it
also is kind of forcing a certain amount
of introspection by the individuals and
a lot of times we're we're just in this
Rat Race and you gotta do that thing and
you do the next thing and and you've got
a plan and someone maybe someone else is
to find the plan for you and all of a
sudden
um that plan has been uh thrown asunder
and now we have the ability to reassess
these things going forward
yeah that's a good point although
there's quite a few people who are you
might say subject to other people's
plans like you know they're they're
being told you still got to show up to
work and
um you know now they got to figure out
how that's going to happen and who's
going to watch their kids and you know
how they're going to make sure that they
stay healthy but but you're right
there's a lot of people right now who
are who have a lot of time on their
hands and they can it's kind of
fortunate that we we live in the world
of technology that we have now where
especially mobile technology so it's so
easy to stay in touch uh for so many
people
um
but it's still not quite the same and
you know one I suppose I just thought of
this now if you didn't want to have
um contact with people uh while they're
reaching out to you electronically you
could just say well I'm not feeling good
today how would they know right or you
could or you could say ah you know my
internet's not my internet is being
overtaxed by all the other people in the
neighborhood who are using it so my
bandwidth is really not working well
right now so so if people could use it I
suppose as an excuse to to get
themselves some free space if they
wanted it you know coming back to this
this notion of uh what's good and what's
bad you know one way we could look at
the introvert extrovert do we talk about
it as a spectrum or uh I'd say a
spectrum is better than a binary there
yeah so maybe what it means to be
extroverted is is valuing as good human
interaction
much more for its own sake than
introverts do and also not viewing like
the what do we want to call it like the
pressure of having to be involved with
other people or being bombarded by their
ideas and stuff not viewing that as as
something that is bad and not being
averse to it whereas the introvert would
would perhaps be more susceptible to to
that and might also value Solitude or
being on their own as something that's
actually good you know
um whereas the uh I guess the extrovert
perhaps doesn't do that I guess I I I
push back against that definition a
little bit because
um like as as more introverted than
expert I don't think that interaction is
a Bad Thing uh and I I value both
um I just know that one is more taxing
on me than the other
yeah I'm not saying interaction per se
would be the bad thing it would be the
sort of being bombarded being having to
go beyond a certain level
um you know a good good catchphrase for
this
um think about the this this is a
meeting that could have been an email
you've heard that yeah before right okay
so so people were saying that before all
of this crisis stuff and there have been
many meetings that probably should have
been an email extroverts are perfectly
fine with that right because they love
showing up to meetings introverts you
know they realize what the hell am I
doing here why am I wasting time with
all this Chit Chat and you know the the
minutes we could have just or we could
have done this through some other thing
too it doesn't have to be an email it
could be like you know meeting virtually
um and and it so it wouldn't be the
meeting per se it would be something
about the meeting exceeding certain
thresholds we might say of
um unnecessariness that the introvert
has has an objection to more than the
extrovert does I don't does that make
does that work or
or are there flaws with that as well you
think
um
to a certain extent like I I work and
worked in Tech and so those tend to be
more introverted people and so the yeah
the meetings tend to be very short and
um oh man you should be in Academia oh
God
uh how about I shouldn't be in Academia
yeah I'm just saying you should be so
that you could experience what what
academic meetings are like this is total
digression but I'll say it and I and
it's it's not all that nice but so you
know before I actually uh worked on on
campus I taught in prisons and so I
didn't have to go to faculty meetings
and then I started teaching uh just in a
regular position and I'd have to go to
faculty meetings and I'd heard all my
colleagues you know at conferences oh
they're so terrible you know and I
thought oh they must be like taking the
wrong viewpoint on it or something like
that and then I started going to faculty
meetings and there's something weird
that happens you have all these really
smart people and usually you'd think
well you put a whole bunch of smart
people together now we've got like a
super group
no something happens in so many meetings
where it's almost like the the
intelligence level of everybody drops in
the meeting setting and things have to
be repeated and they take way longer to
work out and people misunderstand things
or you're like how did you misunderstand
that
um and I don't know if that's just
endemic to academics
um
like going back to our good and bad or
true Goods that like the the good of
trying to get the right outcome is uh
butted up against the good of
um trying to look good in a social sense
and and so even though someone might
have the the wrong uh opinion about the
the first topic they're they're trying
to push their social capital up and so
they're they're going for one good at
the uh Falls of the other or at the at
the detriment to the other
yeah that kind of makes sense actually
that that would be an interesting thing
to explore in some future show you know
what what is actually happening in
meetings yeah we could we could it might
actually be a very helpful topic to
explore yeah just the idea of
what what is the the point of the
meeting if we can all agree the point is
to get the best outcome then maybe that
helps put people in the the right State
of Mind to not be well pushing there's
getting there's getting people to agree
to that sort of on paper or verbally and
then there's actually getting buy-in
from them where where they'd set aside
their own agenda and I think that's a
lot harder to achieve much of the time
right and sometimes they may actually
think that they're furthering the the
fundamental good of the meeting but
they're not really doing so because
they've they've uh identified it so much
with their own hobby horse that they're
going to ride into the sunset so so we
should get to talking about uh our
practice Yeah Yeah for for the week so
do you want to introduce so yeah our
practice this week is uh pause when you
have an impression of the bad and so the
idea is when you
um perceive something that is is that
you have automatically been presented to
your mind to your Consciousness as bad
take a moment and real and look at it
and see is this actually bad or is this
just my perception of it as bad
yeah now this is something that we do
see in a lot of different spiritual and
philosophical traditions
um the stoics made a big deal out of
this Epictetus actually says with every
harsh impression take Applause ask
yourself you know is this what it
presents itself as being impression but
we're going to talk about the meaning of
that term it could also be appearance or
imagination Buddhism has a whole set of
practices uh to to engage these sorts of
things later aristotelians and
platonists do as well you can find this
running throughout you know medieval
philosophy and and I think this is a
very commonly discussed practice but not
a very commonly practiced practice right
and so it could be very helpful for us
right so so when we now it's not to say
that that something is just in our heads
because there are some things that are
actually bad that could happen and but
you know if we take a point as we can we
can distinguish between whether they
just appear to be bad or whether they
really are bad and so appearance uh in
Greek is Fantasia and we use that also
to translate impression it's also the
word we get fantasy from which it you
know originally means something like
imagination so a lot of the time you
know when we we encounter something and
we think that it's it's uh it's bad we
make a judgment about it maybe without
even really thinking it through
we could have uh
we could have you know implanted a lot
in the situation through our own
imagining about it and sometimes we
don't even have to be in the situation
we can just bring it up in our minds and
we are wrong we're already you know Off
to the Races proverbially imagining how
bad this thing is going to be so let's
take a kind of let's take a silly
example
what if you ran out of toilet paper
uh you know well at first of like oh no
what I do but then I take a step back
it's like okay what are the other
options that I have to deal with this
maybe a yeah a warm reg with some soapy
water would be yeah is this is this
really the end of the world what did
people do before this modern invention
existed
and and you know we could take all sorts
of other things you start here's another
great example you start having a dry
cough and you feel kind of feverish it's
absolutely covet 19. it's it's the thing
I feel bad yeah yeah so you you can take
a pause and it might turn out to be that
the bad thing that you think is is
presenting itself really is presenting
itself and it really is bad but you can
reduce your anxiety considerably and
also reduce your sort of panic reactions
uh which might not manifest as panic but
might manifest in terms of other
emotions like anger and irritation with
those around you or sadness or uh you
know morosity or pick whatever else you
want there's a lot of negative emotions
that we experience you can sort of head
those off at the past because our
emotions to some degree are up to us
right another way to look at this is
kind of the
illustration of an optical illusion and
you you first see an optical illusion
and you are given an impression that
like maybe it is a square but then if
you walk around it 90 degrees you look
at it and you realize it's a circle or
some other oblong a weird shape that
only from certain angles does it
actually appear as one thing or the
other and so if you look at this the
same way as you think of things when you
first think of them as bad
take a moment to examine them from
different perspectives and you can
realize what they are in themselves and
take that ability and that moment to
reassess if it's actually bad or just
you thinking it's bad yeah that's a
great way to put it and I I like that
idea of optical illusions because if you
think about how we consume media
we're always looking at optical
illusions right we're looking at these
screens and we have no problem you know
uh looking at the screen and realizing
that's not little people in there in my
phone I'm doing things
um but when it comes to emotional
matters and perceptions of things as
being bad and then responding to them
that way there are quite often a lot of
Illusions along those lines that we
could distance ourselves from and then
kind of look around so this this leads
to another sort of uh key question to
ask about this it's one thing to say
okay try this out do this when things
get tough how do we how do we get
ourselves to be able to do this what do
we need to do is this something that we
would try to do before we get into bad
situations like practice it do some
drills almost what what do you think
absolutely the only way for you to
change the way that you're going to
interact with
um real world examples is if you have
some a framework in your mind in order
to already be able to go oh that's at
hand I can grab that whereas if you are
thrown into
um situations and you have no practice
then you are uh it's going to take you
significantly longer to try to implement
this thing and it might be already gone
you've already passed that moment where
you just accepted it it was bad in the
first place and then just got it that
that's very good so you know living an
intentional life which is what this show
is all about and that's why we're
providing people with these practices
and discussions of all these points it's
partly cognitive right we we get our
heads right about how things are we
think things through that's where the
philosophical theories can often be
helpful but it's also practical we have
to like engage in this sometimes on a
daily on a daily basis
and if we do that then we're ready to
put the ideas into action
um so any final thoughts of the program
well I'm hoping that this sounds good
and works really well because I'm
looking forward to doing more shows in
this format this seems like a really
good way to do it and I'm happy that
we're able to
keep contributing to our our local
community in this way
thank you I think it's it's going to be
a rough ride here for a bit but if we uh
take some time to assess our situations
um I think we could all get through this
a little bit better
yeah that's that's a good way to put it
and and to go back to something we were
talking about earlier
um it really is important this is this
is where we get tested about the things
that we believe and say uh in terms of
right and wrong and good and bad you
know whether we're behaving like good or
bad people and I guess one of the things
that I do want to say is
even if we screw up or if we haven't
been great people in the past we also
have an opportunity now to start doing
things better doing things more
thoughtfully doing things in ways that
do reach out to others
that that over time transform who we are
as people into better people great well
thank you and uh goodbye everyone
foreign